[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بيجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم
مع استشهادي فتاه فلسطينيه برصاصه
اسرائيليه خلال اقتحام الاحتلال مدينه
جنين يشن جيش الاحتلال حمله تعتقالات في
مناطق متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه والقدس
المحتله ويقول انه سيوفر العمل لاحباط ما
وصفه بالارهاب في كل مكان
عقوبه غربيه جديده مرتقبه على روسيا قاده
مجموعه السبع يبحثون بمشاركه تشديد
العقوبات على روسيا وتقديم مزيد من
المساعدات الاوكرانيا بينما ناقش الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفرض حزمه عقوبات جديده على
موسكو وناقشه ايضا محاسبه الطيران على
دعمها العسكري لروسيا
تصعد التوتر
الرئيسيه الشماليه البلاد عقبه تبادل
الاطلاق النار مع الشرطه بينما دعى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وواشنطن الى ضبط النفس
اجتماعا لمجلس الامن القومي في السعوديه
شركه توتال انرجيس ستبدا التنقيب عن الغاز
في الرقعه البحريه رقم 9 في لبنان بدا من
العام المقبل الشركه قالت انها قدمت
طلبيات للموردين من اجل المعدات المطلوبه
بعد اتفاقها مع الحكومه اللبنانيه ومع
دخول اتفاقيه الحدود البحريه مع اسرائيل
حيز التنفي